ça s'est bien passé mais ça va se corser
parce qu'il ya tout qui khaffane pour
qui aujourd'hui est happé dur à cédric
six heures pour les awards de l'année ça
va être une émission exceptionnelle ce
soir ou qui commence à voir la chine ça
va bien si les vous rabattre est bizarre
tout ça alors il paraît que vous avez 5
phuket très forte aujourd'hui qu'il
reste c'est vrai comme d'habitude alors
on le sait que vos chroniqueurs vous
aiment pas ils veulent tous être dans
votre coeur ça normal et bien pour
certains ça restera un rêve mais pour
d'autres suffisait juste de trouver la
bonne technique à savoir en fait l'usure
et à priori ça marche
regardez par l'aide de leur mort est
bien évidemment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pas quand
[Musique]
consultez maintenant est ce que ce n'est
pas ça que tu peux pas tant baissé
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
il le veut la revoir
je voulais dire ça m'a fait rire
franchement c'est tous les jours
vous savez je n'ai pas ménagé tout repos
parce que je mets ça fait plaisir pour
nous savez vous êtes calinous mais
j'aime bien je paye un conteneur a plus
de contact après quoi les choux non mais
ça suffit il n'y a plus de contact on n
en ont peut-être eu tout le monde tout
le monde le sait cyril vous êtes devenu
un petit peu foufou voir un petit peu
dingo mais ce qu'on savait pas c'est
qu'apparemment mais c'est contagieux
ah oui oui il y en a une qui apparaît
mansuy vaut pas ce qu'il peut regarder
on va voir sa maman mamie
oh [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
hagen
[Applaudissements]
allez martinois les chiens trouvés dans
un instant tahrir gracieux en plus il
est plus fort les cherry dans un instant
alors est-ce qu'on a trois autres pukki
de cette semaine qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour nos téléspectateurs en
coulisses pendant les pubs et caetera et
caetera et bien dans l'équipe il y à des
jeunes ou c et des moins jeunes weed man
alors du coup quand ils se rencontrent
et bien on s'aperçoit qu'il ne parle pas
du tout le même langage et parfois même
ils ont du mal à se comprendre
ah comme c'est le cas par exemple pour
eux kelly et bernard et bernard montiel
a coûté 2 12 m et tu vois côté on a fait
un bon tour en quart arrière c'est vidéo
gag mais là là les deux la soirée je
leur ai alors les jo de l'otan se
poursuit
kelly b de venice c'est quand même la
seule mof qui danse mais george osbone
la musique de vidéo gag revenu à dire en
mettez pas regretté
[Musique]
[Rires]
à lui faire du bien de voir un peu
personnes pendant les matches mais
bernard est un est un très beau très
beau bien mais ça pourrait post il
ah ben oui vraiment il est rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai
à chaque fois qu'on dit que si tu as le
malheur de dire oui j'aime bien la zone
il va d'ailleurs ce à quoi je mets qui
croient que c'est un excellent souper
alors même temps je lui disais juste
c'est vrai il s'installe et on papotait
pub et je lui ai dit faudrait qu'on se
voit qu'on déjeune en 2020 un ensemble
de mon nom voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on
bingo c'est vrai ou pas il prépare mais
voilà que trois mâles entendions ces
bêtes lévis jours c'est vrai maintenant
vous êtes amis c'est un gentil c'est
noël ouais
c'est bon quoi amusant c'est vrai nom
c'est bien non ouais c'est très bien
j'ai pas je vous sens bizarre y avait un
truc un truc tu fais quoi c'était ma 10
à dévier deux je les avais vidéo gag et
[Rires]
un bal folk assez dynamique pour ça
montrez nous où sa mère
[Applaudissements]
rien
[Musique]
elle dit souvent ça les 9 et 10 heures à
lui faire du bien de prendre des
vacances
mes remerciements graines en vrai mais
non c'est toi qui me gênait gpc avantage
mais c'est bernard qui me disent tout
simplement tu es pas tout le monde en
grain tout le monde a ses bons et les de
la cua juin mais non il a pas eu un
flash
ça va sinon là les oreilles oui non vous
avez un flash donc une émission du haut
n'ont pas besoin de naufrage sur ces 8
non mais moi je n'ai jamais eu aucun
naufrage en télé ces valeureux jamais y
a toujours marché c'est vrai tout at et
chantilly oise sévit pour l'album sur
ces huit tué alors c'est quoi quoi je
vois un prime tous les deux non c'est
vrai mais ailleurs avant mais c'est vrai
avant midi geoffroy nous apprennent tous
les deux bernard montiel mais non mais
laissez le tout seul ou animateurs verra
tout ce qui se passe tous les bois qu'il
avait reçue après je vous dirais mon
projet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pareil sur ces mines on en reste encore
une chaîne commerciale
bien sûr si vous avez reçu des centaines
de stars et c'est que jean michel n'a
jamais été très grise et lui ça c'est
l'impressionnent pas du tout non non pas
du tout sauf qu'on vous inviter son
mentor celui qui lui a appris à parler
aux femmes c'est à dire camaro away
jean-michel le fun c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
là
bien
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la semaine
chante avec moi je veux une actu brahim
j'ai vu s'il a dit un homme là tout va
et montrer un oui mais là bas et j'ai
l'impression de votre mal de dos elle
allait très mal au dos tito lié à
l'aillet dans son lit avant que tout
soit réuni toute la journée d'hier elle
était seule chez moi même elle était une
belle c'est pas une belle with madonna
non balle était in bed with lara sera
pas tâche c'est pas le monde et elle
valérie demander mieux est-ce qu'elle a
très très mal au dos il faut le savoir
valérie est ce que ça fait d'être allé
la masse et dès demain
bien entendu je vous mettre des pierres
chaudes jean louis cornu oui carrément
elle anime je vous le dis je sais pas si
c'est le fait de trop me côtoyé vous
êtes en train devriez beinheim 7 en
train de passer de l'amitié oui à la
sexualité exactement à beinheim je le
sais joueuses eksi canu
vous êtes comme moi arrêter mais l'autre
frère et d'ailleurs vous avez un frère
oui c'est vrai j'en avais déjà way 1 bat
donc ce n'est pas un deuxième écoutez
benhaim on sait très bien quelles sont
vos intentions
merci mesdames dernière poker poker oui
jovicien lose it
décidément un homme plein de surprises
en plus d'être un grand snipers vous
êtes aussi un artiste un artiste
certains compris mais peut-être qu'une
nouvelle carrière s'offre à vous je
michel regardez ce que fait jean michel
pour les pubs
voilà
[Musique]
[Rires]
salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça vous permet d'occuper respect
des impôts
bien sûr dans leur esprit et dans le
respect de noël voilà l'esprit de noël